hi I'm Eric Voss and this is a breakdown
of The Walking Dead Season eight episode
6 the king the widow and Rick an episode
where Rosita tried to show us fireworks
but as Daryl confirmed and ain't over
till the fat lady sings and gets hit by
a truck alright be saviors leo and Zia
your deaths were hilariously abrupt as
always this episode left us with some
mysteries interesting details connecting
the past episodes and possible subtle
foreshadow winds of future events so
let's break it all down starting with
our big question brought to us by Eddie
on Twitter yeah let's just get this out
of the way Morgan has been revealed as
the crossover character who will appear
on fear The Walking Dead so what does
this mean for Morgan on the main series
could any other characters appear in
through the Walking Dead will this make
me want to watch fear The Walking Dead
now probably not so on the talking dead
actor Lennie James implied that joining
fear The Walking Dead meant he would be
leaving The Walking Dead and going from
my own spectrum based facial expression
reading abilities Lennie James didn't
look too thrilled about it he called the
show fear of The Walking Dead and he
smiled like well at least I get to keep
cashing these checks from AMC now the
timeline appear The Walking Dead is set
three to four years before the Walking
Dead this could mean we will see what
Morgan was up to during that gap period
between resurfacing in the clear episode
in season three production interfered
The Walking Dead moved to Austin Texas
but that doesn't mean that the show will
be set there so for example if fear were
to be set in Madison's home state of
Alabama it's a bit more feasible that
Morgan could bump into that group that
way it's also possible that we'll see a
big time jump on fear The Walking Dead
like the one that we saw between seasons
two and three on the walking dead and
maybe Morgan will leave Alexandria and
the kingdom and meet up with the fear
folks in the present timeline so yes
this doesn't necessarily mean Morgan
will die this season even though I
predicted as much a few times and the
show seems to be setting that Morgan as
the philosophical antithesis to the
cooperative future people like Ric and
Jesus are trying to build the writers
say Morgan has lots of story left on The
Walking Dead we'll see if that lots of
story fills more than two episodes and
like many of you I was hoping fears
relocation of Texas might knee
we would see crossovers from characters
who were in Texas three to four years
earlier in the timeline like Abraham
Eugene and Rosita who yeah could
actually make me want to watch fear The
Walking Dead but Morgan appearing on
fear doesn't exclude those cameos either
like maybe AMC intends to do that and
they just want to keep it as a surprise
overall I believe we're headed toward an
eventual merging of the two series
considering radiant's have been dipping
maybe AMC sees this as a way to combine
the strengths of the two series like on
Survivor when they merge the tribes did
they yet they still do that
hi I'm sure if I were sent that a pirate
season is that still gonna show anymore
I don't know
but enough of this let's get to the real
big question this week to me the most
confusing thing that I'm surprised none
of you asked about why the hell were
Jadis and the other scavengers naked in
that opening scene seriously what was
going on here are there scavengers
closeted nudist colony to or that hoodie
trench coat and boots in the wash I mean
trash people don't have laundry days
people I feel like it's possible the
nudity and the aprons were a nod to
another iconic AMC series Breaking Bad
and the pilot and throughout the show
Walter White stripped down to skivvies
and an apron while cooking meth to keep
the chemical fumes out of his clothes
now Jadis doesn't appear to be cooking
meth here she's actually making these
weird wired trash sculptures my buddy
Scott Porter suggested that people who
assemble bombs using chemicals might do
something similar well I couldn't find
anything about that I don't make bombs
Scott but it got me thinking and it
presents an interesting theory so let's
dive into this with theory time okay
let's look closely at this shot of Jadis
a few interesting things here for one
notice she has three sculptures a pig a
rooster and it looks like those might
have actually been one said she
assembled in the past and now she's
currently working on what looks like a
tiger now remember this episode is
titled the king the widow in Rick and I
think it's possible that these three
sculptures apply to those three
characters in reverse order
Ezekiel the tiger Maggie the rooster
which could be a symbol for the
agricultural society and Rick as the pig
may be connected to how Jada sees him as
sort of a
Pig for the slaughter like how she threw
him to Winston before or last season or
maybe it's a medic connection to Rick
slaughtering those pigs outside the
prison look guys this is theory time I'm
just like pulling strings here
there's also another nude aprons
scavenger bringing Jadis some materials
that we can't really see meanwhile a few
others are stripping parts and wires out
of a car
so perhaps Jadis is packing these
sculptures with chemical base explosives
planning to deliver each of them to the
three communities kind of like Trojan
horses that go boom boom that might
explain why later when Rick enters the
junk yard area the sculptures have been
tucked away nowhere in sight now of
course another way to look at these
sculptures it's just Jadis replacing
what was stolen from her remember her
back in season 7 Rick swiped Jada's cat
sculpture after forming his shaky
alliance with her let's actually go over
all the other connections to past
episodes in our segment callbacks so
throughout this episode Gregory calls
Maggie Margaret now this is a callback
to Gregory intentionally calling Maggie
by the wrong name during negotiations
with her in season 6 and 7 of course
that all ended when Maggie punched him
and demanded to be called mageary
margaret is technically her name and the
closest Gregory can get to maintaining
this dickish insubordination meanwhile
over at the kingdom Carol snaps at young
Henry to stay away from her trying to
scare him by telling him that little
kids one drop would turn them hamsters
this is the same scare tactic Carol used
on Sam in season 5 warning this boy not
to follow him or else the monsters will
get him which they did Carol is haunted
by the deaths of children around her
salmon season 5 & 6 Lizzie and mica in
season 4 and of course the first kid to
wander off in the woods and turn into a
monster her own daughter Sophia we
learned this episode that Rick's
Polaroid's were indeed intended as proof
for these scavengers that the Savior's
are in retreat we saw him taking these
Polaroids throughout season 8 which also
calls back the Savior's taking Polaroids
of their victims in past seasons later
this episode we see Maggie fiddling with
this pocket watch this of course
belonged to Glenn it was an image that
was on Steven Yun's tidal slide in
previous seasons before that this watch
belonged to her father Hershel he passed
it down to Glenn as a wedding gift and
now Maggie carries it as a
touken of the loved ones that she has
lost and a symbol of her resolve
remember this watch was the closing
image of season seven as maggie
delivered a rousing war cry to avenge
the deaths of Glenn and Abraham so as
Maggie considers what to do with these
save your captives and with Gregory the
fact that she's holding this watch tells
us cold-hearted justice is a main thing
on her mind
then when Carl finds Sadiq and recruits
him he remembers his mother and says
quote you got to do what's right it's
hard to know what that is sometimes
sometimes it isn't Carl is directly
quoting Laurie's final words to him and
her dying breaths back in the prison in
season three you got to do what's right
baby promise me you always do what's
right it's so easy to do wrong in this
world so it feels wrong to try do track
or later be shown Abruzzi to spy on
those saviors Leon Z and if you listen
closely you can hear Zia saying Rick the
prick don't know [ __ ] about the fat lady
here so there's our answer fishbowl last
week when Regina mentioned the fat lady
we all speculated that this could be a
tank or an armored car or even a
helicopter instead the fat lady is this
truck rigged with massive speakers to
blast an opera singers voice to lure
Walker's away and appropriate in a much
more straightforward than what I
imagined and yeah I'm a little bummed
that we never got to see it in action
too bad Darrell isn't much a fan of
opera speaking of which Rosita blowing
up Leo with an RPG is the same shocking
boom boom that Darrell used on the
saviors in season six it's almost like
Darrell Rams the fat lady to keep Rosita
from stealing his thunder and it's
interesting how at the end of the
episode Jadis marks Rick's shipping
container with an A this seems like a
callback to terminus at the end of
season four when Rick and the others
were held in a train car marked with
that same letter a Rick being trapped
inside this container definitely feels
like they screwed with the wrong people
moment except in this case Rick kind of
let himself get screwed with twice maybe
Jadis writing a here means she could
have been part of terminus in the past
just bear with me here maybe she used to
know Garrett then she's a fellow
cannibal who survived and started her
own society of trash people or maybe
she's a fellow terminus
prisoner and escapee who learned this
letter based captive system from Gareth
and the other terminus people and Ric
might be able to use that history to
connect with her and form an actual
alliance I will see this episode
connected with the comics and two
interesting ways so let's review those
in our segment well in the comics so the
first comic connection is the
introduction of the character Siddiq in
the comics the dick shows up after these
current events way in the future and
personally speaking he's not too
exciting of a character so I'm excited
to see this apparently more thoughtful
adaptation of the character there is a
second connection to the comics that
might interest you if you have read the
comics but if you haven't and you don't
want to get spoiled don't worry you can
just skip to this time to completely
avoid me discussing this and stay
totally spoiler free or if you don't
care you can just keep watching through
this section but any spoilers will be on
you cool cool okay Wow discussing
options for what to do with these save
your captives Gregory makes an
interesting suggestion to Maggie build
the gallows already now Gregory might
have just been trying to appeal to
Maggie's frustration with Jesus for
feeding the captives after all we just
saw him kissing negan's Astin saying he
was his man and we don't really know
where Gregory stands either way
obviously he can't be trusted but the
fact that he mentions gallows could be
some sneaky foreshadowing here because
in the comics way later Maggie after
dealing with one shady betrayal after
another from Gregory decides enough is
enough and makes an example of his
treason it is a huge moment for Maggie
that weighs on her heavily so if this
show ends up going in that direction
Gregory's initial suggestion here to
build these gallows could be super
ironic but let's move on from that and
talk about the deeper meaning this
episode how do all these characters
storylines fit together at the matically
okay again this episode is titled the
king the widow and Rick Ezekiel Maggie
and Rick the leaders of the three
communities who according to orders from
me again are not supposed to be killed
now what I find interesting about this
episode is these three leaders butt
heads with rivals to their leadership
from within their own ranks
Carl summed up this challenge to
authority to Sadiq earlier saying quote
sometimes kids have to find their
way to show their parents the way Carl
challenges his father's wariness of
Siddiq bringing Siddiq into the
community after Rick tried to scare him
off with warning shots in the season
premiere at the same time trigger-happy
fighters like Daryl Michonne Rosita and
Tara defy Rick's war strategy each
driven by their own selfish a vengeance
for the scars that the Savior's left
them now it's too soon to tell if them
finding their own way will be rewarded
but in this episode at least it results
in a short-term victory for Daryl and
the rest robbing the saviors of a
critical tool that could have rescued
them from their Walker blockade
meanwhile Rick sticking to his plan
resulted in him sweating it out as a
captive of the scavengers the king
Ezekiel also faces a challenge from
below with Carol shaking him out of his
post defeat depression but really it's
the widow Maggie who proves to be the
wisest of the three appearing to heed
the advice of both of her challengers
she concedes to Jesus's diplomatic
solution by creating a humane prison for
the Savior's but she also accepts
Gregory's more cutthroat solution by
promising to Jesus to kill them
eventually and she of course turns that
justice on Gregory as well
proving that among the challenged
commanders of the king the widow and
Rick the widow ends up being the most
decisive okay let's check in on this
week's kill count going by our normal
tabulation Sadiq would top the list we
saw him take down five walkers plus he
told Karl in the past he put down a
hundred thirty seven Walker's total will
give or take a few which yeah is a lot
but let's be honest from a shock-and-awe
standpoint Rosita was totally the
deadliest this episode this lady fired a
rocket launcher at a person in doors
standing feet away from her like maybe
don't ask Rosie to open a window she
might blow a hole in your wall a
question for you guys do you think
Rick's strategy is too cautious or
foolish are Darrell and the rest right
to defy his plan I wanna hear your
thoughts down below or you can tweet me
directly a da vas and follow new rock
stars on Twitter at new rock stars for
updates on her videos and like and share
this video and subscribe to new rock
stars for deep analysis of all the stuff
that you love check out all my
breakdowns for the first five episodes
of the season and more theories and
insight into season 8 of The Walking
Dead and if you really love this channel
and you want to help us grow you can
contribute to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our
donors especially Laurie dinning thanks
for watching guys bye